tu sais ce que je ne comprends pas
comment diable es-tu encore en vie tu
as dû être un très mauvais imbécile la comète que
tu vois dans le ciel en ce moment
passe au-dessus de la terre tous les six ans
provoque un portail
mais quand il est ouvert nous recevons un visiteur  d'
une galaxie lointaine
le poète guerrier au sens de la science-fiction
l'homme de l'espace il vient ici
chercher un combat avec vous
le jiu jitsu choisi mais s'il ne l'
obtient pas
il reste et il tue tout ce qui
est politique extraterrestre 5-15
maintenant vous êtes tous des
combattants de jiu-jitsu choisis
mais tant que vous mourez courageusement
personne d'autre n'aura à le faire
il est fou comme moi
il n'y a aucun honneur à tuer un fou
je peux voler aussi
toi